30 seconds to on air
okay and you are just here
now an extraordinary story about a young
man who many years ago visited Prague
what he found there with thousands of
refugees that the mercy of Hitler's
imminent Invasion
do you ever think about the children and
what happened to them
I have to use some stories
that's really not about me
we are working to evacuate these
children
my train to Safety in Britain why are
you doing this
because I may be able to do something
about it I must
go
Nikki you must know we cannot save them
all you have to forgive yourself that
I'm starting to I have to finish it
we cannot let these people down
it is incredible what you achieved
we're doing as much as we can
a lot of faith in ordinary people
because I'm an ordinary person
save one life save the world but forgive
me but how many children are we speaking
about
can I ask is there anyone in the
audience tonight who owes their life to
Nicholas Winton
[Music]